teachers can play a tremendously
powerful role in creating a growth
mindset culture and there are a variety
of different strategies and approaches
they can use to do that one way the
teachers can powerfully role model
growth mindset is to really have a
growth mindset about each one of their
students to really authentically believe
and communicate to their students that
they expect each and every one of them
to be successful um that they that they
believe that with um with the right
strategies and the right effort uh each
one of their students can be successful
in their class and reach really high
levels just as important as
communicating that idea is as a teacher
to communicate the idea that they're
there to support them in that process
not that i believe you can do this
you know and good luck but rather i'm
here to help you i'm here to help coach
you and to help you
learn how to uh really learn how to grow
and be successful in my class i think
another strategy that teachers can use
to create a growth mindset culture is to
focus on the process of learning uh to
focus not on the outcomes not on the
grades that students get but rather on
the process of of growing and of what
strategies they can use to improve their
work but it can be really helpful and
encouraging for them it can build their
sense of self-efficacy
and help them see that they are in fact
growing even if they're even they're not
getting the best grade if their teacher
really calls out the specific things
they're doing well
now that can be challenging and time
consuming for teachers that means really
reviewing the work that students are
doing to be able to recognize and call
out those good strategies but it can
really pay off because it directs
students attention to making sure that
they're using those good strategies
and help them see
you know success and whatever that
discipline is whether it's math or
science or literature as a combination
of learning and mastering these
different strategies and they can see
themselves growing and being
acknowledged for for being successful in
those those
kind of mini steps along the way to
becoming really great in that subject i
think another really important way that
the teachers can role model a growth
mindset
is through through the way they talk
about themselves about their own
learning journey and and in the way they
approach mistakes creating an
environment in which mistakes are
celebrated uh is is really really
powerful
an environment in which students don't
have to worry about making mistakes
because they understand that their
teacher won't look down on them and the
the contra that in contrast
those mistakes if they pay attention to
them are like important hints as to what
they can do uh to to ultimately to
improve some teachers will actually make
a point to make mistakes themselves
um uh they'll kind of inject mistakes
into their own teaching uh in order for
their students to really be on the
lookout for mistakes and so then they
can model how you should react when when
you do make a mistake so for example
when their students uh catch them making
mistake the teacher shows uh isn't
defensive at all in the face of that
mistake they don't try to sweep it under
the rug and set instead they might say
thank you you know thank you so much for
fixing my mistake let's let's think
about why i made this mistake let's
think about what strategy i can use to
prevent myself from making that mistake
again and in that way the teacher is is
kind of modeling they're providing the
kind of mental scaffolding that students
ultimately need to engage in themselves
that way when they make their own
mistakes
they'll understand what's the what's a
healthy way to react to that mistake